what a day for the buccaneers this uh
gent
after a monumental season in the nfl
just becoming
a major big time grown-ass man in this
grown-ass man league
hopped on a horse and rode it around the
circumference of raymond james stadium's
super bowl playing field
this is a guy living his best life
joining us here on the rich eisen show
from the world champion buccaneers devin
white how are you devon
i'm doing good i mean sure are look at
you i'm watching this
ride what's the name of that horse that
you rode yesterday
devon dream so it is dream it's the same
horse that you you've been riding around
this in
your last few years then huh
nah i got i got plenty of hoists man i
switch them up all the time okay
on a different one so uh is this the
same horse that that went viral with you
riding around getting ready for your
draft
back in the day nah that was uh for the
draft draft
now that was a different horse okay what
was this like for you this ride
it was good uh to be able to uh go
go on a different field different venue
and with the uh super bowl grass still
down you know all the super bowl stuff
still up
and uh host of the lombardi trophy my
around one of my
my precious animals it was it was very
good
and uh it was like you know just
just fun man just best of both worlds
for me man because you know i love scuba
and i love horses of the best of both
worlds at one time
uh how to dream like it because that
might have been the the greatest piece
of turf that horse has ever
uh stepped on as you know that thing is
as manicured as it gets
a super bowl feel that's crazy though uh
that's crazy because
green is pregnant and i haven't been
riding at all she's just been sitting
down here just
uh you know just getting ready to have a
baby but obviously you can ride horses
all the way up until the final weeks of
the pregnancy and i was like um
man i don't care even if she ain't
rolled up because most time you want to
have them rolled up
and you know ready to perform but i just
pulled it straight out like hey
you you know what to do let's do it and
she and she gave me a good ride
she did you can see i could look i'm not
an expert um
you know my wife is actually and uh you
could just see the hor
i don't know just looked like the horse
was the stride that you had going
it it looked like it was a celebration
yeah she did a good job man i was really
proud of her
for uh you know not having been enrolled
in so like many many
like a couple months you know since i've
been here i was around there first and i
was like i'm gonna just let her chill
but i had to get that moment with her so
i know she was probably happy and i'm
happy that we could share that moment
together wow that's awesome devin white
here on the rich eisen show let's get
into the game devin
um what were you able to do
that you uh you thought going into the
game this is what we're going to do
what what did you pull off that you you
felt so confident that you could
what exactly was it i feel like going in
the game i feel like we were uh
as a defense as a whole i felt like we
knew we could uh
affect uh my own timing you know
with the pass rush and on the back end
uh we feel like we can get the guys up
front
enough time to actually get after him
you know and not just let him
you know uh get quick throws or what's
not and
i feel like we all play uh everybody had
a hand in on that game
and i feel like we all executed and we
had our
minds we had our mindset right and you
know you see with the team
that's all in what they can accomplish
so after the game devin you called the
chief's offense
gimmicky what did you mean by that i i
call him gimmicky
yeah you know mostly he's in the lead
you know they line up
you know they do what they do they run
the ball they run the ball well
and they after the run they you know
create play action or drop back pass or
whatever
but man they they like to do like a lot
of eye candy
which i which is like a gimmick like
because that's not r i ain't gonna say
it's not real football but
it's not modern day football you know
they add a lot of special stuff to that
game
but all that stuff right there it just
it's not what it is so i mean we was
able to pick up on it and
we was able to stop it but you know say
like a team that
come right at you you know it probably
would have been a different fight but
they had like a lot of gimmicks to run
the person across the field
make him run up the field make him run
in do this do this do that
and you know everybody know what gimmick
is it's not natural something that's not
natural
what would you say uh devin to the um
i guess argument um post super bowl 55
with the chiefs not looking at all the
way that they've looked in
any other game that mahomes has been
starting uh that it might have been a
different result
had the two starting tackles for the
chiefs been out there
what do you say to that uh i mean it is
what it is they wasn't out there
and whoever was behind it they would
have won the game yeah man that's what
god that's what these guys are here for
they step
in and we don't miss a beat you know
it's always going to be
that but at the end of the day when we
played green bay we had two story
safeties out and then nobody say
you know oh y'all y'all just so good
when y'all was able to get it done
or uh did nobody say aaron rodgers
couldn't even go
and uh couldn't get the job done and
they had two two safeties out but
we're gonna give this team all the glory
of because they didn't
have uh their two tackles and i don't
think that's right
at the end of the day i feel like
whoever was out there i felt like our
team would have did a great job
against them um so i mean that is what
it is they wasn't out there
i mean i hate that they wasn't out there
because obviously you want to always
play a team at full
at full go so you know you know the best
on best but
i mean it's not my fault i can't control
what happens over there but
i knew we was ready to play and i feel
like that back up should have been ready
to play as well well i guess devin white
let me let me ask
questions about the playoffs as a whole
uh before we get to the future
um the when uh when aaron rodgers
uh on uh fourth down in that nfc
championship game down eight trots off
the field and mason crosby comes on to
kick a field goal were you surprised
in that game yeah i thought yeah mom
jefferson
i thought they would give him a shot you
know four down territory
and i think the amount of points they
were down i thought that was going to
give him a shot to uh
you know get a touchdown you know but i
truly believe we would have stopped him
again you know we had stopped him so
many times in a row
because uh the great coverage was
playing you know we've been playing some
good
reds on defense up in the uh postseason
so
i mean then it would have left them
getting no points at the end that
probably would have been another story i
don't know but
i mean i thought they would man aaron
rodgers a great quarterback
i know if i'm a coach uh i want the ball
in his hands at the end of the game
brother
he get it or not at least i uh when i
swing devin white here on the rich eisen
show you were the first draft choice of
bruce arians what did he say to you on
the phone
when they drafted your fifth overall
2019.
well b.a already told me on my top five
visit if i was available at
pig fire that he was gonna take me and
um
i mean he was a man of his word so when
he got on the phone he just said i told
you i was gonna get you if you was there
i was like you did and then i was like
man we got business and he was like hey
get your running shoe
you know we do like let's get to work
like we already knew
what the goal we wanted and we already
knew what type of players
that he needed to get that goal and we
talked about it so i mean
all this is not really a surprise to me
you know it happened a little faster
than what i probably thought but
at the rate that our defense was going
last year i knew
we were just one step away no i know you
said after
the the game as well that um you are
pleased that todd bowles
uh is staying put um and what has he
done what does he do
how good is he to unlock you and connect
you with levante david behind that
defensive line with jack barrett
showing up and showing out he arrived in
the same year that you did
uh from denver uh much unheralded now
look at him i'm wondering what he does
devin yeah i mean ty bulls is the
mastermind of it all you know in my
opinion uh
he's the best defensive coordinator in
the nfl just because he uh
he's a he's one of those defensive
coordinator that you really don't have
to fit his scheme you know
he works with the players that are
already in the scheme and he makes the
scheme fit those players
and he called his plays according and a
lot of people don't do that but that's
one thing
ty bull does and man i really applaud it
man he always put everybody in the best
positions you know
some games like he feel like the person
needs to do this or a person need to do
that
and he's mainly always right because he
watched so much you know he's probably
the first i know for sure he though he
the first and second coach in the
building all the time
i think coach moore was the only coach
that beat him in the building
and be there like 4 30 a.m every morning
uh even earlier so that just let you
know what type of dedication
that he puts into this game and um you
know him getting his credit is well
deserved because he put the work in
devon uh devon white here on the rich
eisen show champion super bowl champion
tampa bay buccaneer a few more minutes
left with
with him uh first time you met brady was
when when's your first meet tom brady
kevin oh man i won't say we came in for
count okay first time i mean
i know he was one a lot of guys would
come down
but i mean i was in the country i was
doing my thing so i was like hey you
gonna have to wait t.b
but now we came in for uh campus stuff
that was the first time
what do you mean you were in the country
what are you talking about what does
that mean
right tom brady was in florida and i was
in louisiana where i'm from
that's the country okay
so then what was your first conversation
with him like because i'm
picking up a lot of pride from you devin
in every word you say that you
you are a serious serious professional
and brady uh i think would definitely um
uh float to that sort of mentality and
you to his
uh i'm wondering what that is like for
you yeah we we had already talked on the
phone
probably you know when he uh first
signed him and stuff but uh
when i first met him in person i think
it was like uh we were just talking
about a
you know about training camp and you
know we need to we need to uh
we need to get it going basically
because we need to win now and uh
man everything has been history ever
since you know because obviously the
quarterback over there i'm the
quarterback on my side of the ball
and it was like hey you know let's go
let's go fight for it all
so um where would where you know
obviously there was a lot made of your
horseback ride i assume you were in the
boat parade too
right devon oh definitely okay who are
you on the boat with
i was on a big red boat with lavonte
um shaq jpp donovan
rojo uh leonard fournette
uh lesson mccoy there was a couple that
like i think that was a couple of us on
there uh
right now ryan went on there i think
that was that was it though
just us boys and uh had a couple more
people on there a lot couple coaches on
there okay
the family members on there all the
players you know all right did you see
uh the video of uh
the way your quarterback left the event
devon you see
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah a lot of people
left the event like that
you know why not why not turn up well
just won the world championship
right what you holding back for don't i
i
understand um did you walk out of this
event like this
and the video wasn't no okay are you no
i'm not a drinker but even if uh i was
drink i knew i wasn't gonna drink on
that day because i still had to go ride
that horse
[Laughter]
that was the main event is what you're
saying dream the dream ride
was the main event yeah for you
okay so but i agree with you you know
that to me that's one of the most
relatable tom brady moments in the
history of tom brady
was the way that he was trolling that
was dope oh man he really
man tom put in a lot of work this season
and i
promise you he probably ain't had a
drink all season 2301
he probably had a drink all season you
know uh
and that guy is very dedicated to his
craft his body
his mind he like you know the amount of
work he put in and man he was just
letting it all
out because and the thing was i don't
blame it man that parade was one of the
best parades i've ever seen in the
history of parades
it was thousands of boats out there it
was thousands of
people lying on the side of the stream
that we were slowing down and it was
crazy i didn't even know
tampa bay had that many people i ain't
never never been into that part of tampa
bay that we was right
well i guess last one for you then devin
uh or two i got two more for you
uh last one for you if brady had flipped
the lombardi trophy
towards any body on defense
whose hands would you trust the most
on defense yes sir either
sean murphy bunny number one yep
mike edwards number two yep and devon
white number three
yeah you gotta be first
nah i gotta push on first yeah i mean
you but you
you've got it we got a uh we got a best
hands and a pick list up in the locker
room
and it's gonna be he first on it so i
gotta just keep giving him his credit
i ain't gonna take his credit from him
okay so where are you on that list in
the locker room
i'm i'm two i'm two on the pig list
right i got some awful playoff bits
count a little more than just one pick
and you know all my picks came in the
postseason um
and um you know hands i got great hands
you know you've seen the one from drew
brees i
snagged that so i'm i'm top five on the
hand
but uh smb and mike elvis they they got
the best hands all right so you give
you give some props to to your teammates
but i i
again that that's part of your game that
makes you
particularly special is that the way
that you can go
sideline to sideline shoot a gap meet
someone in the hole
uh cover somebody and then grab it not
be one of those guys where somebody uh
in the booth goes well that's why he
plays defense and not offense that you
you grab it and you take it to the house
how much better can you get
like what is your mentality here devon
before i send you on in the rest of your
day
oh my my ceiling doesn't have a ceiling
on it it just keep going upward
you know just as long as um i'm able you
know just physically healthy
i'm gonna go out there and i'm gonna put
the work in to perform to keep getting
better and better
and there's always going to be little
things i can um improve in on my game
whether even it's not directly football
it might be my body wise that
hey i did something to help me get even
quicker twitch you know
i'm going to always be uh trying to gain
notes and
tilt like uh last off season i tried to
uh do the tb12 band workout and
you know just to get the flexibility and
stuff that he does and
i feel like it helped you know i
continue doing it in my drills that i do
just to make me a better football player
and um
you know and i'm gonna just keep going
up every year it's gonna be something to
work on
you know until i'm done playing the game
and that's just that's my mentality so
it's like if i if i was in the car you
know the car ain't got no roof because
it ain't no ceiling we just don't keep
getting better and better
devon white i have enjoyed every last
second of this conversation
do not lose my number because uh i'll be
asking you to call it and vice versa
anything uh anytime i really appreciate
the the time congrats on
the championship you're first uh
hopefully of many and i really love
watching you play thanks for the call
yes sir thank you mayor have a good day
you too that's devin
white hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that
watch more right here